herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren seit über einem jahr werden
in diesem jahr grundrechte eingeschränkt
deutlich intensiv und es wird hart darum
gerungen wie weit man dabei gehen kann
die bahn dabei gehen muss und dass wir
das nicht machen ohne einen guten grund
ein kunde einen guten grund zu haben das
ist allen klar es geht nämlich darum
leben und gesundheit zu schützen leben
und gesundheit der anderen auch zu
schützen und dass das ein guter grund
ist das hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
in seiner entscheidung sein
entscheidungen von gestern noch einmal
klar gestellt dass es viel schon darüber
gesprochen worden
aber ich will es noch mal ausdrücklich
zitieren dann dass es wirklich noch mal
eine bestätigung dessen warum um
grundrechte eingeschränkt werden es
dient nämlich einem grundsätzlich
legitimen zweck der gesetzgeber verfolgt
in erfüllung seiner
verfassungsrechtlichen schutz pflicht
das ziel leben und gesundheit zu
schützen sowie die funktionsfähigkeit
des gesundheitssystems als überragend
gewichtigen gemeingut sicherzustellen
meine damen und herren ich raten allen
das noch mal intensiv nachzulesen das
zeigt doch mal um was es eigentlich geht
genau darum geht es
aber genauso klar wie beschrieben ist
warum grundrechte eingeschränkt werden
können genauso klar ist auch wann
grundrechte eben nicht mehr
eingeschränkt werden können nämlich dann
wenn dieser gute grund wegfällt
meine damen und herren und nachdem das
rk ii als wissenschaftliche expertise
eben gezeigt hat aufgezeigt hat dass für
geimpfte und für genesene also
immunisiert diese diese begründung nicht
mehr trägt weil sie eben andere nicht
mehr infizieren können zumindest in
einem deutlich geringerem maße als
andere dass sie andere nicht mehr
gefährden können und auch sich selbst
nicht mehr
dann fällt dieser grund weg und dann
können grundrechte in einem rechtsstaat
auch nicht mehr eingestellt werden
deswegen ist die
die heute vorgeben auf der ganz
konsequente schritt und deswegen werben
in zukunft ausgangs und kontakt
beschränkungen für geimpfte und gewesene
nicht mehr gelten
und ich höre dann oft die dürfen jetzt
alles meine damen und herren über was
reden wir denn da wir reden darüber dass
in zukunft menschen die im pflegeheim
über monate hinweg keine kontakte mehr
hatten alleine in ihren zimmern essen
mussten und es schmerzhaft auch gespürt
haben dass die in zukunft wieder im
speisesaal zusammen essen können und
worüber reden wir noch wir reden darüber
dass in zukunft vielleicht am muttertag
geimpfte ihre mutter besuchen können und
eben nicht da besucht dann auf eine
person beschränkt ist darum geht es um
geimpfte und genesene die in zukunft von
dem ausgangs- und in kontakt
beschränkungen ausgenommen sind meine
damen und herren es ist ein wichtiger
schritt und das ist ein
rechtsstaatliches gedroht
das werde es diese zuordnung auch
dringend geboten sie werden die ängste
und gelesen werden in zukunft
gleichgestellt mit denjenigen die einen
test vorlegen können beim einkaufen beim
friseur eben auch weil durch die durch
die impfung und durch die erkrankung und
damit die immunisierung festgestellt ist
dass sie andere kaum noch infizieren und
damit gefährden können meine damen und
herren rechtsstaatliche grundsätze
gelten nicht nur in normalzeiten sondern
sie müssen gerade auch in krisenzeiten
gelten deswegen das ist ein ganz
wichtiger grundsatz integriert jetzt mit
leben erfüllen es geht darum aufzuzeigen
wir leben in einer lebhaften demokratie
und wir leben nicht noch in einem
rechtsstaat sondern wir leben
einen rechtsstaat und dann müssen diese
grundsätze auch durchgesetzt werden
und ich kann alle die jetzt mit ungeduld
fragen warum ich nicht und dann sind wir
denn dran all denen kann ich nur sagen
wir alle müssen gemeinsam mit hochdruck
daran arbeiten dass diese schritte in
die normalität
alsbald eben nicht nur für geimpfte und
für genesene gelten sondern wir alle
diese ersehnte normalität wieder und
zurückerarbeiten
wir sind auf einem sehr guten weg die
zahlen zeigen dass die inzidenz zahlen
die entspannung vielleicht ist es zu
weit hergeholt aber zumindest es nicht
mehr diese überlastung auf den
intensivstationen ist ein wichtiges
signal und lassen sie auch deswegen
verantwortungsbewusst aber auch unter
einhaltung aller rechtsstaatlichen
grundsätze dass wir alles in die
normalität wieder finden können vielen
dank der bundespräsident es heute bei
129 1 also gefallen
jetzt hören wir normalen wolfgang
kubicki beschwören hinweis die haft die
fraktion wird zu top 44 keine teilung
der frage beantragt hat sie beantragt
werden teil ist jetzt dass wir später
namentlich abstimmen ich weiß weist
darauf hin dass wir nach der bekanntgabe
des ergebnisses damit schon über dem
sektormittel beratung abstimmen müssen
also teilung der frage ist beantragt und
so dass das nachfolgetreffen auch schon
mal ja das habe ich schon gesagt also
bist du zu hören wir vielleicht auch
nicht schlecht also jedenfalls kleidung
der frage und dann nahm dieser anteil
will ein teil dieser geteilt frage
nächster redner wie der kollege ulrich
pohl fw fraktion und genau noch
zuzufügen ist das den vollen impfschutz
nach neuesten zahlen des rk ii bisher 86
prozent der bevölkerung haben
herr präsident meine damen und herren
liebe zuschauer
wir als fdp fraktion fordert schon seit
langem die normalisierung der
verhältnisse und die beendigung des noch
bei uns in deutschland
diese forderung kommt nicht von ungefähr
sondern beruht auf wissenschaftlichen
grundlagen zum beispiel einer studie von
professor unitis und der stanford
universität
er gehört zu den meistzitierten
wissenschaftler unterwelt er kommt zu
dem ergebnis dass lok dass keine
signifikanten einfluss auf die
ausbreitung von kompetenzen haben die
restriktiven maßnahmen sind
epidemiologisch sinnlos richten ob
enormen schaden an die gleiche
auffassung vertritt imago
wissenschaftler die wünschen haben
festgestellt dass die korona welle 3
auch ohne buntes notbremse bereits vor
ostern ausgebremst
entsprechend haben deutsche gerichte in
den letzten monaten viele anordnungen
art wurden da diese keine ausreichende
wissenschaftliche grundlage mit der
vorliegenden verordnung wollen sie
kämpften oder genesenen mitmenschen
einen teil ihrer verfassungsmäßig
verbriefte grundrechte wiedergeben
jedoch werden millionen andere weiterhin
diskriminiert
für uns ist die verordnung der
bundesregierung oder gesetzentwurf der
coco weitere schritte auf dem weg zu
einer impfpflicht durch die hintertür
wir fordern die bundesregierung auf die
resolution 23 61 des europarates vom
januar 21 1
dieser wird gefordert dass in den
mitgliedstaaten keine diskriminierungen
geimpfter folgen kann
diese resolution wurde übrigens auch für
mitglieder kroko mitgetragen
meine damen und herren resolutionen des
europarates haben nicht nur gültigkeit
bei sanktionen gegen andere staaten
sondern auch für die demokratie in
unserem land
ich fordere die bundesregierung daher
auf geben sie uns die grundrechte zurück
in ihre schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmeverordnung schreiben sie dass es
sich bei den vorgesehenen
erleichterungen und ausnahmen von
schutzmaßnahmen nicht um sonderrechte
oder privilegien handeln würde
stattdessen nennt sie es ich zitiere die
aufhebung nicht mehr gerechtfertigter
grundrechtseingriffe faktisch wird damit
das grundgesetz zu einem privileg denn
das dauern verbriefte recht gilt eben
nicht mehr grundsätzlich für jeden
hierzulande
sie teile die bevölkerung in zwei
gruppen doch auch die kämpfenden
genesenen können ihren privilegien nicht
sicher sein denn sie operieren auch hier
mit hintertürchen zu gebe es ich zitiere
besorgniserregende virusvarianten nicht
weiter genannte zusätzliche gründe sowie
besondere regelungen die dazu führen
können diese freiheiten wieder zu
kassieren
hören sie auf die menschen zu
verängstigen und gegeneinander
auszuspielen
in den öffentlichen anhörung der letzten
wochen könnten wir im
gesundheitsausschuss aber auch im
unterausschuss pandemie hören dass
wissenschaftler die ansteckungsgefahr
befreien als äußerst gering einschätzen
beenden sie daher die unsägliche masten
pflicht und freien öffnen sie die
spielplätze für unsere kleinsten die
biergärten und gaststätten im
außenbereich lassen sie uns sport und
gängelei treiben und hören sie endlich
auf die freiheit zu ersticken geben sie
die wieder den menschen luft zum atmen
liebe gott ist die liebe groß ich weiß
dass es schwer ist bei großen
herausforderungen die richtige strategie
zu finden
da gebe ich in einen ratschlag
orientiert sie sich an der realität
berücksichtigen sie die neuesten
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse waren
sie ihr gesicht und gestehen sie den
menschen und sich selbst ein dass es
sich gehört haben
beenden sie den lock darin und damit
alle verbundenen grundrechtseingriffen
sie ich werde bei den zuständen hier
daran erinnert was 1980 passiert dass
das zentralkomitee der sed hat damals
auch nicht gemerkt dass es vorbei ist
denn sie wollten es nicht merken auch
dann nicht als viele menschen auf dem
straßen waren ihnen wird es wie diese
sozialistische riege ergehen wer zu spät
kommt den bestraft das leben
vielen dank herr kollege
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nächster redner ist der kollege thorsten
frei cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen herüber wenn
man ihrem während vortrag zugehört hat
dann ist man wirklich versucht
verfassungsrechtliche nachhilfe zu geben
es ist unglaublich was sie hier
vorgetragen haben denn es ist doch
keineswegs so dass die grundrechte die
wir in unserem grundgesetz stehen haben
alle gleichzeitig unbeschränkt gelten
können
darüber hinaus steht in den grundrechten
drin dass sie durch gesetz eingeschränkt
werden können und ein letztes sprechen
sie wenn sie darüber sprechen bitte
nicht nur über die grundrechte die in
form von schutzmaßnahmen eingeschränkt
werden müssen sprechen sie auch darüber
warum wir dieses grundrecht einschränken
wir schränken es deshalb ein anderes zur
geltung zu bringen nämlich das recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit darum geht es
und sie können nicht die
gesundheitlichen folgen dieser pandemie
einfach ausblenden weil es schöner wäre
ohne schutzmaßnahmen ja es wäre schöner
ohne schutzmaßnahmen aber das leben ist
nicht so wie man es sich wünscht sondern
wir haben hier herausforderungen in
verantwortung vor der bevölkerung zu
treffen und das tun wir das sollten sie
nicht diskreditieren und legen sie eine
zwischenfrage von frau von storch ja
es gehört zum parlamentarismus dazu und
zur sache herzlichen dank dass sie die
zwischenfrage genehmigen
welchen effekt hat es auf die
grundrechte der anderen wenn ich um 22
uhr alleine auf die straße gehen
welchen effekt hat dass zum schutz der
grundrechte anderer menschen können sie
begründen warum ich nicht mehr auf die
straße gehen darf und alle anderen auch
nicht worauf man stolz wenn sie das
möchten dann mache ich das gerne noch
mal aber ich war selbst an so vielen
debatten hier im haus beteiligt wurde es
von unterschiedlichen kollegen gemacht
wurde und dabei ist immer darauf
hingewiesen worden
es geht bei einem diffusen
infektionsgeschehen nicht um eine
einzelne maßnahmen
es geht nicht nur um eine ausgangs
beschränkung sondern es geht um die
summe der maßnahmen die wir zum schutz
der bevölkerung getroffen haben und
diese summe die hilfen ein diffuses
infektionsgeschehen in den griff zu
bekommen es nutzt doch nichts frau von
storch wenn der herr böhme das
bestreitet fakt ist vor zwei wochen
haben wir hier das vierte
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz gemacht mit
der bundes notbremse
wir haben heute eine 7 tages incidents
von 129 vor zehn tagen waren es noch 169
man kann natürlich alles abstreiten aber
das sind die positiven folgen dieses
gesetzes und das sollten sie zur
kenntnis
heute ist in der tat in der tat ein tag
der hoffnung und der freude weil wir 460
tage nachdem das erste mal nach einem
cockpit 19 ausbruch in deutschland
berichtet worden ist wie licht am ende
des tunnels sehen und vor zwei wochen
ich habe vorhin das vierte
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz angesprochen
da ist doch hier im hause auch von
unterschiedlichen seiten beklagt worden
dass es keinen impfstoff geben
ja das sehen wir heute doch auf 30,6
prozent der bevölkerung hat heute eine
erste impfung gestern war ein weiterer
tag mit über einer million impfungen
wenn das kein im turbo ist dann weiß ich
auch nicht was sie darunter verstehen
und das verschafft uns das licht am ende
des tunnels und deswegen werden wir
jetzt alles notwendige tun um diesen im
erfolg nicht zu gefährden sondern dafür
zu sorgen dass wir auch die letzten
meter dieser pandemie noch gut
bewältigen können
natürlich feiern morgen sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der jacke zu liegen
vielen dank herr kollege frei sie haben
eben von einem tag der hoffnung
gesprochen und ich habe eine sachliche
frage zum § 6 der ausnahmeverordnung
dort geht es um die regelungen für den
sport und die beschränkungen bei der
ausübung des sports und die formulierung
die dort gefunden ist ist allerdings aus
meiner sicht unklar und deshalb würde
ich sie gerne fragen dürfen nach dieser
verordnung wenn sie denn beschlossen
wird dürfen nach dieser verordnung
vollständig geimpfte und genesene
zumindest im freien wieder
uneingeschränkt sport treiben dann
sollte man das zumindest sagen sollte es
nicht zu sein dann wäre ich ihnen für
eine begründung dankbar
der gesetzestext bzw der verordnungstext
ist in dieser frage nicht eindeutig und
viele warten auf eine entsprechende ein
entsprechendes signal das wäre dann auch
ein zeichen der hoffnung
also zunächst einmal herr kollege hahn
ist es so dass wir mit dieser verordnung
beziehungsweise die bundesregierung tut
es ja wir stimmen der heute nur zu dass
man mit dieser verordnung den ersten
schritt auf dem weg geht das ausnahmen
von schutzmaßnahmen und erleichterungen
die geimpften und genesenen gegeben
werden können
und da geht es um die quarantäne da geht
es um die ausgangs beschränkungen die
kontakt beschränkungen
da geht es darum dass man die getesteten
den geimpften gleichstellt oder
umgekehrt und es geht um den bereich des
sports im paragrafen 6 den sie
angesprochen haben im grunde genommen
ist es so dass wir bei den regelungen
die wir im paragrafen 28b zum sport
getroffen haben das heißt zum
individualsport im freien deutlich
machen dass dieser sport möglich ist
wenn es sich um die impfte oder gelesene
handelt damit ist diese regelung aus
meiner sicht sehr klar und das ist der
erste schritt auf dem weg in die
hoffnung und es werden weitere schritte
folgen per hand und das muss man
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen an der
stelle auch ganz deutlich sagen ja es
ist der erste schritt und wir haben
diesen spagat zu gehen einerseits diese
pandemie zu bewältigen und auf der
anderen seite die frau justizministerin
hat es sehr deutlich in ihrer rede
gesagt dafür zu sorgen dass bei denen wo
es keine rechtfertigung für die
einschränkung von grundrechten gibt auch
dafür zu sorgen dass sie diese
grundrechte wahrnehmen können
und jetzt ist es so dass wenn man sich
das mal anschaut welche grundrechte
werden denn eingeschränkt nicht in allen
fällen werden diese beschränkungen
aufgehoben mit dieser verordnung das ist
klar
es gibt leichte beschränkungen wie das
tragen der mund nasen bedeckung der
abstandsregeln der hygiene und
schutzkonzepte das werden wir auch den
geimpften zukünftig zumuten müssen damit
wir zum schutz derer die nicht geimpft
werden können oder auch nicht geimpft
werden wollen
auch die pandemie gut bewältigen können
aber es gibt auch andere einschränkungen
beispielsweise im bereich der
berufsfreiheit die wir ja mit dieser
verordnung auch nicht aufgeben und
deswegen wird es weitere schritte auf
diesem weg geben müssen und es wird sie
auch geben und ein wichtiges mitglied
dieses haus hat heute morgen in einer
zeitung die frage gestellt warum hat man
das denn nicht vor zwei wochen im gesetz
im infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt darum
haben wir im paragrafen 28 c des
infektionsschutzgesetzes eine
verordnungsermächtigung gemacht diese
frage kann man klar beantworten weil wir
flexibilität brauchen weil wir antworten
brauchen falls es schwierige virus
mutationen gibt die unter umständen von
impfstoffen licht umfasst sind und weil
der weitere im fortschritt auch dafür
sorgen wird dass wir tatsächlich in
weiteren bereichen erleichterungen und
ausnahmen machen können
deswegen werden wir uns schon sehr bald
wieder mit dieser frage zu beschäftigen
haben herzlichen dank der thorsten frei
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unionsfraktion
hat es noch mal ganz klar gesagt auch
mit dieser verordnung fallen nicht alle
einschränkungen beispielsweise das
tragen eines mund nasenschutz hatte ja
genannt
das bleibt nach wie vor bestehen ja und
in der verordnung steht auch das ja
mindestens 14 tage vergangen sein müssen
nach der zweiten bzw der letzten impfung
wenn man dann bis man dann sozusagen
wirklich als vollständig geimpft gilt
und daneben kontakt und ausgangs
beschränkungen wegfallen
seit märz wissen wir vom robert koch
institut das von immunisierten person
kein nennenswertes infektionsrisiko mehr
ausgeht und trotzdem wurde von ihnen mit
der bundes notbremse herr frey ein
gesetz verabschiedet in dem die rückgabe
der grundrechte gar nicht vorkommt ihre
begründung geben hat mich überhaupt
nicht überzeugt
denn es ist bezeichnend für ihre politik
dass sie bei den grundrechts
einschränkenden maßnahmen sehr schnell
sind weil der frage der rückgabe von
grundrechten an genießen und geimpft
lassen sie sich leider sehr viel mehr
zeit
meine damen und herren grundrechte hat
man von geburt an und zwar auch und
gerade in pandemie zeiten da haben sie
völlig recht frau ministerin lambrecht
wir haben zur bundes notbremse einen
änderungsantrag eingebracht der die
rückgabe der grundrechte
verfassungskonform und
umfassend geregelt hätte den haben sie
aber leider abgelehnt meine damen und
herren
und sie haben jetzt auf eine
rechtsverordnung verwiesen das müssen
wir noch mal klarstellen die eigentlich
erst am 28 mai hätte in kraft treten
sollen
jetzt haben sie aber angst bekommen dass
ihnen das bundesverfassungsgericht zuvor
kommt und dann muss man ja auch mal
feststellen dass hat die
verfassungsbeschwerde unter anderem der
fdp-bundestagsabgeordneten zumindestens
schon mal bewirbt sie sind aufgewacht
und haben auf schnellem wege als
ursprünglich geplant diese
rechtsverordnung hier vorgelegt die
führt jetzt richtiger weise zu mehr
freiheit und das begrüßen wir ganz
ausdrücklich aber sie geht uns längst
nicht weit genug denn freiheiten für die
impfte und genesene werden nicht
scheibchenweise zugeteilt frau
ministerin lambrecht es gibt keinen
ersten und zweiten schritt herr frey
freiheitsrechte gibt es nur als ganzes
meine damen und herren
und es ist auch nicht nachvollziehbar
dass wesentliche freiheitsbeschränkungen
gegenüber genießen weiterhin gelten
sollen
die verordnung klammert vollständig die
öffnung von gaststätten von hotels von
freizeit und kultureinrichtungen von
sport- und fitnessstudios für genesene
und geimpfte aus es ist kein grund
ersichtlich warum die impfung und genese
nicht gemeinschaft nicht gemeinsam
mannschaftssport betreiben können meine
damen und herren es ist auch nicht
ersichtlich warum der gastronom der
selbst gekämpft ist sein lokal nicht für
genesene und die impfte öffnen kann
unser grundgesetz schützt in artikel 12
auch die berufsfreiheit und erreicht es
auch nicht aus dass sie eventuell
irgendwann mal in einem zweiten schritt
das problem lösen sie wollen doch hier
nur eine neiddebatte verhindern denn die
vermeidung von neid ist aber kein
verfassungsrechtliches gut meine damen
und herren wir enthalten uns hier weil
wir zwar diese die eine rückgabe von
freiheiten sehr begrüßen freiheiten gibt
es aber nicht scheibchenweise sondern
nur als ganzes und genau das ist inhalt
unseres entschließungsantrages befehlen
dank meine damen und herren der die fdp
wird sich bei der abstimmung über diese
verordnung also enthalten das wurde
gestern auch schon angekündigt christine
aschenberg-dugnus hat das jetzt noch
einmal bekräftigt für die liberalen und
zudem werden sie hier über einen einen
entschließungsantrag vorlegen in noch in
dem noch mal anders formuliert ist was
eben der fdp nicht weit genug geht
beispielsweise dass es auch für geimpfte
kein mannschaftssport geben soll oder
auch die öffnung der gaststätten und
hotels ist ein thema bei der linken bei
der verleihung bei der fdp in diesem
entschließungsantrag jetzt kommt aber
die linke zu wort eben person von
susanne fesche entfällt dieser sind sie
selbstverständlich wieder zu gewähren
es ist also folgerichtig für geimpfte
und genießen einige beschränkungen
wieder zurückzunehmen und deswegen
stimmen die ihre rechtsverordnung auch
zu aber es ist ihre aufgabe als
bundesregierung die freiheitsrechte für
alle bürgerinnen und bürger
wiederherzustellen
dieser permanente
und macht die menschen möbelrücken
lockdown bundes notbremse und heute nun
die ausnahmeverordnung alles im hugo
fand und kanzlerkandidat laschet hofft
wahrscheinlich immer noch auf schönes
wetter aber weder mit europa fahren noch
mit dem prinzip hoffnung besieht man
eine panne die dafür braucht es einen
plan und ich bin in dem drei punkte
nennen wir uns wichtig sind erstens ein
schnelles impfangebot für alle hätten
sie so wie von uns gefordert die patente
freigegeben werde schon lange mehr
impfstoff zur verfügung und werden
deutlich mehr als die acht prozent
bislang in 68 fordern mit geräumigen
freigabe der patienten besonders
menschen in zu kleinen wohnungen jeden
tag im überfüllten office zu arbeiten
müssen und nicht im home-office bleiben
können stecken sich häufig an
dies sind im übrigen besonders stark von
den einschränkungen betroffen denn es
macht einen unterschied für eine
vierköpfige familie in der drei zimmer
wohnung ohne balkon und garten von einer
ausgangssperre betroffen zu sein als in
der villa in dahlem mit 1300
quadratmeter grund nehmen sie die
menschen in prekären lebens und
arbeitsbedingungen in den blick und
machen sie diesen ein schnelles
impfangebot
der zweite punkt werden sie konsequent
während sie allen bis in die wohnzimmer
hinein vorschriften machen haben sie
bislang die wirtschaft mit
glacéhandschuhen angepackt
es ist doch unglaublich das anderssein
beschäftigten verboten wird fsb zwei
masken zu tragen
nehmen sie endlich die unternehmen
stärker in die pflicht und bestrafen
verstöße beim arbeitsschutz konsequent
unter dritte und letzte punkt wir
brauchen eine andere politische
weichenstellung die anfälligkeit für das
virus ist das ergebnis einer politik die
seit drei jahrzehnten
betriebswirtschaftliche kriterien
anwendet und nahezu alle
gesellschaftlichen bereiche auf profit
getrimmt hat die konsequenz überfüllte
busse und bahnen kinder die nicht
geschult werden können pflegekräfte die
am limit sind und gesundheitsämter die
völlig überlastet sind und so weiter und
so weiter
jetzt muss in die bereiche investiert
werden die dem wohle der allgemeinheit
dienen statt solidarität zu predigen ist
dass die solidarität die sie der
bevölkerung schulden schön lang war das
für die linksfraktion die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
also die linke wird hier der verordnung
zustimmen weil sie in die richtige
richtung geht auch einige bundesländer
haben ja diese verordnung nicht
abgewartet sondern haben teile der
regelung bereits umgesetzt und die
impfung etwa negativ getesteten
gleichgestellt aber heute soll das ganze
auch bundesweite auf den weg gebracht
werden manuela rottmann für die grünen
sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
bekräftigen heute einen
verfassungsgrundsatz eine
verfassungsrechtliche
selbstverständlichkeit und zwar leider
nur per verordnung sobald tiefe
grundrechtseingriffe im einzelfall
niemanden mehr nützen müssen sie
gegenüber diesen personen sofort
aufgehoben werden wir sind nach wie vor
in eine
zwischen situation die belastung in den
intensivstationen ist immer noch viel zu
hoch und deswegen müssen wir auch eine
klare sprache sprechen
heute werden nicht etwa die kontakt
beschränkungen für geimpfte aufgehoben
sondern von takkt beschränkungen unter
vollständig geimpften und das ist ein
wesentlicher unterschied
wir wissen aber dass geimpfte selbst in
den seltenen fällen einer erneuten
infektion keine schweren verläufe mir
durchleiden müssen deswegen nutzt es
niemanden wenn sie sich untereinander
weiterhin nicht mehr zwischen dürften
auch nicht im überlasteten beschäftigten
auf der intensivstation
die übrigens selbst und das freut mich
wenn sie es wollten zu der gruppe
derjenigen gehören die bereits geschützt
sind
man kann dem verfassungsrecht über viele
streiten darüber dass diese
beschränkungen aufgehoben werden müssen
kann man nicht streiten
das ist etwas so als ob man in frage
stellen würde ob 1 und 12 ergibt die art
und weise wie politikerinnen und
politiker der koalition diese debatte
aber angefangen haben war für mich eine
der tiefpunkte der letzten monate
angefangen beim notorischen horst
seehofer dessen abwegige argumentation
ich hier überhaupt nicht wiederholen
will
in der weihnachtspause dann die meldung
rechtspolitiker von union und spd prüfen
ein gesetzliches verbot von
sonderrechten für menschen mit corona
impfung und dem januar waren die
bundeskanzlerin vor angeblichen
doppelten privilegien für geimpfte damit
schürt man leitet warten und das ist das
letzte was diese gesellschaft geraten
war weder von der bundes
die besserung noch zum bundesweiten ist
da war da eine klare ansage zu hören im
gegenteil
jens spahn hat erstmal den ethikrat mit
dieser frage beschäftigt als ob es da
irgendetwas zu prüfen gäbe
der ethikrat ist gut und sinnvoll für
viele dinge aber wenn ein bundesminister
eine verfassungsrechtlich glasklare
frage zur disposition stellt dann stellt
sich mir eine andere frage ob er sein
verfassungsrechtlichen kompass während
der pandemie verloren hat oder ob er je
einen hatte 1&1 ist 2 und damit muss man
nicht den ethikrat beschäftigen
sie hätten besseres zu tun gehabt wir
hätten mit beginn der impfkampagne eine
einfache fälschungssichere dokumentation
haben müssen heute haben wir 24
millionen menschen die in deutschland
geimpft sind wir haben diese
dokumentation immer noch nicht
verfassungsrechts ist das grundgerüst
des vertrauens in dieser gesellschaft
und es darf auch während einer pandemie
nicht beschädigt werden denn wir
brauchen dieses vertrauen auch in der
nächsten krise
es ist gut dass wir nach diesen irma
notierungen heute den menschen das
vertrauen zurückgeben können
dieses ist ein freiheitliches land wir
brauchen solle solidarität aber wir
erwarten keine schikane aktion gewissen
die grünen und da passen doch noch mal
die aktuellen zahlen vom robert koch
institut heute also die impfquote steigt
in deutschland haben 30,6 prozent der
menschen mindestens eine corona impfung
erhalten den vollen impfschutz erhielten
bislang allerdings nur 8,6 prozent der
bevölkerung aber die zahlen das ist
schon angesprochen worden es geht voran
allein gestern wurden 1,1 millionen
menschen geimpft zuhörerinnen und
zuhörer mit diesem gesetz beschließen
wir nichts weniger als den einstieg in
die rückkehr zur normalität liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es stecken sich
immer weniger menschen
der fraktions zahlen gehen zurück und
alle experten sagen dass die dritte
welle gebrochen ist und deswegen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen können wir
nicht mehr notwendige beschränkungen
aufheben und das war auch mal machen wir
mit diesen regelungen hier
wir haben sehr schnell die grundrechte
der bürger ganz erheblich beschränkt zum
gesundheitsschutz das war gerechtfertigt
aber genauso schnell müssen wir jetzt
seien diese beschränkungen die wir nicht
mehr benötigen dann auch wieder
aufzuheben
wir haben den bürgern viel zugemutet ja
aber das hat wirkung gezeigt und das war
auch der grund dass das
verfassungsgericht gestern die anträge
zurückgewiesen hat wenn über rinnen und
bürger das virus nicht mehr übertragen
können dann stellen sie keine gefahr
mehr dafür andere und auch nicht für
sich selbst und deswegen können wir hier
diese beschränkungen aufheben für die
geimpften und für die genesenen und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir die
ausgangssperren die kontakt
beschränkungen und auch die quarantäne
pflichten jetzt aufheben und dass wir
dafür sorgen mit diesen regelungen das
negativ getestet bestimmte einrichtungen
also wenn sie in den zoo möchten oder
wenn sie in zum friseur möchten dass
dann geimpfte und genesene genauso wie
negativ getestet behandelt werden und
genesen und geimpfte keinen test
benötigen
auch das ist ein ganz wichtiger schritt
zurück zur normalität liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen jahresvergleich
verhandlungen führen aber wir müssen
doch sehen dass es nur für einen
überschaubaren kurzen zeitraum sein wird
ich hoffe für wenige wochen
viele bundesländer sind dabei die im
priorisierung aufzunehmen es ist zu
lesen für astrazeneca auch für ganz
deutschland in absehbarer zeit also
dieser zeitraum wurde die
ungleichbehandlung haben der wird
überschaubar sein und ganz nebenbei
gesagt ich finde es muss auch einen
anreiz geben sich impfen zu lassen
denn ich glaube dass wir in wenigen
wochen schon nicht mehr das problem
haben werden zu wenig impfstoff zu haben
sondern ich fürchte es wird das problem
geben dass es zu wenig bürger gibt die
sich impfen lassen wollen und das kann
es dann auch nicht sein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und ja auch ist der vorwurf zu hören es
sei ungerecht dass jetzt gerade die
älteren mehr dinge tun dürfen obwohl sie
ja auch schon zuerst geimpft wurden
da ist zu sagen dass wir ganz genau die
familien und die kinder im blick haben
wir wissen dass die kinder und die
familien die jugendlichen im moment am
meisten unter der pandemie zu leiden
haben und gerade deshalb war es so
wichtig dass das kabinett gestern zwei
milliarden zur verfügung gestellt dafür
dass aufhol paket das wir den
kinderbonus beschlossen haben um
zumindest ein stück weit die eltern
finanziell zu unterstützen
es ist eine gute nachricht dass die
zwölfjährigen sich bald impfen lassen
werden und auch dass wir von der
notbremse eine ausnahme für kleinere
gruppen von kindern zugelassen haben
dass die sich treffen können dass sie
sich austoben können das war auch ganz
wichtig also er kann sich eine
zwischenfrage des kollegen straetmanns
aus der fraktion die linke
vielen dank herr kollege die frage
knüpft an das anders der kollege h neben
schon gefragt hat einfach nur zur
klarstellung für alle und für beruhigung
auch für mich selber da ich immer noch
gerne mit ihr auch mit ihnen zusammen
fußball spielen dürfen genesene und
geimpfte demnächst diesem
mannschaftssport oder auch andere
mannschaftssportarten wieder ausüben
also das ergibt sich aus § 6 dass der
sport wieder ausgeübt werden kann
unabhängig von der regelung des 28 b von
geimpften und genesenen und ich freue
mich bald wieder mit dir lieber
friedrich kicken zu können
beide geben
[Musik]
noch nicht aber das training man
benötigt
ich hoffe wir sehen wenn wir gegen fc
machen wir das natürlich stellt sich
dann die frage zu recht von der fdp
wenn ein wirt geimpft ist wenn ein
kellner genf ist und wenn die gäste gfc
ist da noch die ansteckungsgefahr und
deswegen ist richtig dass der nächste
schritt schon sein wird auch handel und
gastronomie und auch den tourismus zu
öffnen aber wir sind jetzt erstmal bei
der persönlichen lebensführung bei den
unmittelbaren persönlichen
lebensumständen und für die lassen sie
uns erst mal diesen ersten schritt gehen
und dort die beschränkungen wieder
zurücknehmen also wir sind froh der spd
hat hier tempo gemacht dass wir in
dieser woche den bundesrat erreichen und
ich hoffe dass möglichst viele hier auch
zustimmen
wir wollen den bürgern die grundrechte
wieder zurückgeben es geht nicht dass
menschen von denen keine gefahren mehr
ausgehen weiterhin beschränkungen
unterliegen und lassen sie mich zum
schluss auch noch einen satz sagen weil
wir wie ich finde ein jahrhundert urteil
des bundesverfassungsgericht hatten zum
klimaschutz lassen sie uns mit der
gleichen energie die wir die korona
pandemie bekämpfen mit der gleichen
entschlossenheit auch gegen den
klimawandel vorgehen
das ist vielleicht noch die größere
bedrohung für unsere gesellschaft vielen
dank fraktion und das thema klimaschutz
übrigens und das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes das wird den
bundestag auch morgen noch mal
beschäftigen und morgen am nachmittag
also das kann morgen thema jetzt bleibe
weiter bei der verordnung über die
gleich abgestimmt werden so hören jetzt
marc jan marco luczak für die union
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
also liebe frau kollegin rottmann sie
wissen ja ich schätze sie sehr aber bei
ihrer rede ist doch ein bisschen etwas
verrutscht wenn sie die minister sparen
vorwerfen seien verfassungsrechtlich
was ist wenn sie ja behaupten wir würden
die bürger schikanieren
da muss ich mich doch fragen wo sie hier
gerade geredet haben sie haben hier im
deutschen bundestag geredet und nicht
auf einer grünen
nominierungsveranstaltung da ist doch
eigentlich ist an dem sich und diese vor
polen
wir sind uns sehr bewusst wir sind uns
sehr bewusst dass die schutzmaßnahmen
die wir in den letzten 14 monaten
getroffen haben dass die einschneidend
haben dass viele menschen auch darunter
gelitten haben natürlich war uns klar
und das war auch ne zumutung an vielen
stellen aber ich sage genauso es war
richtig dass wir diese schutzmaßnahmen
getroffen haben weil wir entschlossen
das infektionsgeschehen in den griff
bekommen mussten und das ist auch
gelungen
das ist uns gelungen und das war wichtig
dass wir das gemacht haben weil es auch
eine verfassungsrechtliche notwendigkeit
war nämlich unser grundrechtlichen
schutz pflicht zu entsprechen nämlich
das leben die gesundheit von vielen
menschen zu schützen
und genauso notwendig genauso
verfassungsrechtlich notwendig wie es
war diese schutzmaßnahmen zu ergreifen
genauso verfassungsrechtlich notwendig
ist es jetzt auch die freiheiten
zurückzugeben wenn menschen nicht mehr
infektionen sind weil sie genesen sind
weil sie geimpft sind dann gibt es für
freiheitsbeschränkungen keinerlei
rechtfertigung mehr und deswegen war uns
als unions fraktion auch die spd uns mag
ist wichtig dass wir das schnell machen
und deswegen muss ich ehrlich sagen habe
ich überhaupt gar kein verständnis wenn
jetzt hier von der linken kritisiert
wird das sei irgendwie ein
hau-ruck-verfahren gleichzeitig sehr
wales freigeben wollen ja was wollen sie
denn sie müssen sich nun entscheiden
wollen sie schnell den menschen ihre
freiheiten zurückgeben oder wollen sie
das kritisieren das kann nicht sein das
ist widersprüchlich so wie sie hier
argumentieren und deswegen will ich auch
noch sagen im kleid weil auch das hier
angesprochen der bussi aussagen das ist
wirklich fehl am platz es geht hier um
die wiederherstellung grundrechtlichen
freiheiten es geht nicht um sonderrechte
es geht nicht um privilegien und
deswegen wäre es aus meiner sicht auch
ein wirklich verfassungsrechtlich
verfehltes gleichheits verständnis wenn
man jetzt rücksicht nehmen würde auch
nicht geimpfte und das hinauszögern
würde kein nicht dem staat
etwas davon wenn wir menschen die
geimpft werden ihre freiheit
vorenthalten und deswegen war es richtig
dass wir hier gemeinsam aufs tempo
gedrückt haben und ich will noch einen
punkte ergeben weil die fdp also gesagt
hat wir müssen jetzt alles freigeben für
alle ganz egal was da will ich auch
schon deutlich widersprechen
natürlich ist es so dass uns die
wissenschaftlichen studien sagen dass
geimpfte weniger infektionsgefahr haben
weniger 80 prozent das ist etwa die
gründe
das heißt dabei es gibt auch ein
restrisiko und deswegen muss man schon
sehen wenn wir alles zu lassen bei immer
noch hoher intelligenz und kollege frei
hat richtigerweise auf handy mit 129
sind wir jetzt wir sind ordentlich
runtergekommen
aber wir sind immer noch bei 129 wenn
wir jetzt alles öffnen dann müssen wir
auch der gefahr ins auge sehen dass sich
dieses restrisiko realisiert und gerade
wenn es um gastronomie wenn es um
geschlossene räume geht wenn es dieses
risiko nach wie vor da und deswegen muss
es doch jetzt unser anliegen sein die
inzidenz weiter runter zu kriegen und da
sind wir auf dem richtigen weg und wenn
das gelungen ist dann bin ich sofort bei
ihm wenn wir wieder unter die 100
gekommen sind dass wir dann auch weitere
öffnung schritte machen bei kunst und
kultur im einzelhandel
und auch in der gastronomie das wollen
wir machen aber noch nicht jetzt jetzt
geht erstmal um die grundrechte sind
sieben bereiche und das machen wir heute
und da bin ich auch für um zustimmung
dankeschön sprecher der unions-fraktion
und das haben wir noch einen redner hier
zum abschluss dieser debatte bevor dann
abgestimmt wird über die vor monaten
auch übrigens noch über einen weiteren
gesetzentwurf aber dazu gleich mehr
wir hören jetzt letzten redner stephan
stracke für die union herr präsident
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
geimpfte und von corona genesene werden
befreit von testpflicht ausgangssperre
kontakt beschränkungen in quarantäne das
ist der kern der vorliegenden verordnung
und das machen wir weil geimpfte und
genesene keine relevante gefahr mehr für
sich und andere sind deshalb ist impfen
so wichtig impfen rettet leben es
schützt und ist der schlüssel raus aus
der pandemie und wir kommen beim impfen
spürbar verabschieden
über 30 prozent unserer bevölkerung ist
das erste mal geimpft das sind fast 25,5
millionen menschen über sieben millionen
sind bereits vollständig geimpft aktuell
werden im wochenschnitt jede sekunde
fast acht personen geimpft jede sekunde
fast acht personen geimpft das ist doch
ein großartiger erfolg den wir gemeinsam
hinbekommen haben und deswegen gehen wir
diese schritte und gefährden auch nicht
diesen großartigen erfolg meine sehr
verehrten damen
hier kommen tag für tag spürbar voran
und das macht er hoffnungsvoll für den
sommer und ich sage ein großes
dankeschön an die mitarbeiter und die
ärzte in den impfzentren an die
hausärzte und fachärzte das was sie
leisten ist ein wesentlicher beitrag zu
diesem erfolg danke impfen ist der weg
zurück zur normalität und wir machen
jetzt einen ersten wichtigen schritt
weitere werden folgen und es ist gut
dass die länder bei einer inzidenz von
unter 100 weitere öffnung schritte gehen
können und dies auch tun testen und
impfen macht den unterschied
und meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren mit den vorliegenden
änderungsgesetz stellen wir den
versorgungsanspruch bei einem
impfschaden durch eine kurve 19
schutzimpfung klar wir schaffen
rechtssicherheit insbesondere in fällen
in denen ein impfstoff im einzelfall
abweichend von den empfehlungen der
länder zum beispiel für andere
altersgruppen eingesetzt wird und wir
ziehen auch regeln zum wechsel
unterricht und zur ausnahme
möglichkeiten von untersagten
präsenzunterricht glatt dieses unter
anderem wichtig für hochschulen für
berufsbildende schulen jetzt kann
praktischer unterricht zum beispiel in
laboren in krankenhäuser zweifelsfrei
gestartet werden und aus und fortbildung
von polizisten rettungsdienstkräfte und
feuerwehrleuten können auch im
präsenzunterricht durchgeführt werden
voraussetzung dafür ist eine zweimaliger
test in der woche das gesetz und die
verordnung enthalten wichtige
klarstellungen und ausnahmen
erleichterungen für geimpfte und für
corona genießen im personen wir sind gut
unterwegs ist hoffnungsvoll das was wir
beschreiten für den sommer lasst uns
entschlossen so weitergehen
[Applaus]
jetzt die redner und er hat auch noch
mal angesprochen was hier mit beraten
wird in erster beratung allerdings eine
änderung noch mal im
infektionsschutzgesetz wo es unter
anderem darum geht dass neben ärzten
künftig auch apotheker nach tragung im
impfpass vornehmen können und so weiter
das wird aber erstmal überwiesen jetzt
wird aber über die verordnung über die
lockerung für die impfung genesen
abgestimmt schriftliche erklärung nach §
31 der geschäftsordnung vor
entsprechend unseren regeln nehmen wir
diese ins protokoll auf der ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner beschlussempfehlung
aufdruck sage 29 1397 der verordnung der
bundesregierung auf drucksachen 29 1257
zuzustimmen
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
danke wir stimmt dagegen danke er
enthält sich
danke die beschlussempfehlung ist mit
den stimmen der koalitionsfraktionen der
fraktion die linke und der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen gegen die stimmen
der fdp fraktion bei enthaltung der fdp
fraktion angenommen
so schnell geht das dann in der tat
damit hat der bundestag zumindest den
weg frei gemacht für diese verordnung